こんちくわｈざはうｓｋはいと言うわけで皆さん歌
カラオケとか歌いますか？結構もお
カラオケとか皆楽しむ物
だと思うのですけども歌には
歌詞というものがあります
歌詞ってものには
まあ曲に込められた
メッセージとか
意味合いとか 伝えたい事とか
あの歌詞には
いろんな意味が込められてる
と思うんですけれども
まぁ...
あの、音楽を聴いただけでも
その曲の意味をこう自分の中で
理解して飲みこんで
僕の知らない曲でも
歌詞を当てれるんじゃないかっていう
なので今回は
2人は知ってて
俺だけが知らない曲を
ジョイサウンドから見つけて貰って、
僕、一回聴くんで
僕なりにちょっと解釈して
歌詞を付けます
作った歌詞が合ってたら
その音楽だけで
そのメッセージ性を読み取ったって言える
たくみふくしゃちょー：確かに確かに
逆に凄くない？？
たく：凄いと 思う（笑）
たなっち：まぁ、逆じゃなく凄いですよねー
僕のその今日は、想像性というか
独創性
音楽を聴くだけで
メッセージ性を
自分の中で
解釈できる力を
ちょっと皆さんに見せようと思います
いつでもオッケーです
たく：オッケー
たく：え、どうする？
たな：分からないってなるともう結構マニアックになっちゃいますよね
たな：今のいけたんじゃないですか？
たく：じゃあこれ行っちゃいますか
たな：これ行きますか
一回聞いていい？とりあえず
(笑)
たく：あ～じゃあほぼほぼもうチェンジだな
全然(笑)
え！？
一番好きだわ
分かんないわ！
たく：嘘！？
分かんない分かんない
たな：えー俺は絶対知ってると思いましたこれ
俺もこれ絶対知ってると思う
普通に好きそうな曲ではあるんだよねたぶん
あー俺知らない今の
たく：え、てかジャンル的に知らないはずがないよね？
うん
分かったちょっと頑張ってみます
なんとなくイメージは掴んだんで
まあ曲の雰囲気さえ掴めば
僕はもう歌詞生み出せるんで
うん（お～）
頑張ってみます
どうでした？
たく：かすりもしなかったね
たな：だって、歌詞無い所で歌って
たな：歌詞あるところで
(笑)
分かんないわ！
たく：はい！
たく：お待ちください
まじで分かんなかった今
たく：では、流します
はい！お願いします！
ノリやすそうだったんだよな、曲は
どうでした？
たな：もう殴り合いでしたよね
トゥッハッハ！！！
たく：あ～いけそうな気がする
たく：たぶんね、知らないいんじゃないかな？
さあ来い！！！！
こんな感じでしょ？
たな：余裕ですね(笑)
たく：行きまぁす
ふぇい！
えい！
エンディング♪